Listen up, ladies.
If your period cramps are completely unbearable
that you cannot stand them,
it's like labor pains. You need to listen to this.
If you are waking up in the middle of night
because you're cramping so bad that you can't even walk the next day,
or you wake up fatigued and dizzy and almost hungover
every single morning, that is not normal.
For the better half of the last decade,
I have recommended this supplement,
this very specific magnesium by Bio Emblem.
It's a triple magnesium complex.
It is the only one on the market.
And I have tried thousands of magnesiums.
Nothing has ever compared to this.
I went the last two months without it,
and even my husband was like,
what the hell is different with you?
My mood swings, my muscle cramp,
my fatigue. I couldn't take care of my kids.
I never knew how important it was until I went without it,
because I've been on it for so many years.
And I found it on TikTok Shop,
so I bought it. Now I have three bottles.
Get it now during their holiday haul. Guys,
the link is right there. It literally could not be easier.
And I used to buy this from a different big box store,
and this was like $7 cheaper.
So TikTok shop for the win.
Hit the link. You will not regret focusing this holiday season
on your health and your wellness.